μέσα σε ένα γύπεδον γιαπαράδειγμα το γάσει επί το οποίο έγινε μια λλαγή τουραστικού ταπιτα
προπέρσι το οποίο είναι ξίγουρα και με έξωδα του κράτους περισσότεριο καιι του γάις πι
αν εξερέσ το γάσεις επεί κανένα ναλοστάδιο δεν πληρί τις ελάχιστες οδιαγραφές για να κάνει
κάποιος ως την πρωτημασία και σίγουρα και ο κλειστο στίος έναν κομμάτι εκατό μέτερα κλειστώ
δεν έχουμε δέκαμέρες ίκσήμερες να πείτ το κλίμα μαστε πάρα πολλάκαροναι αλλά για να αθριτί
που είναι στο ψηλιόν επίπεδο ι πέντεμέρες ηθιόμερες που να χάσεις μασημαντικό ρόλο άρακυρια κόμου
θεωρίσ ότι σαν ευρωπακεί χώρα υστερούμε πολύ σε στο κεφάλιο υποδόμες πρέπει να γίνουν πολλά
πράγματα πόμι ώστε να πούμε ότι έχουμε φτάσει σε να επιπεδο κανοπιτικό για τους επαγγελματιες
αφλητες θεωρώ ότι στερούμε πάραποληκαι είναι είναιείναι πραγματικά τις περίεργον γιατί η κύπρος αυτήτι στημέχουμε
μάρτιο νανκι είμαστε μετοκοντομάνικο ηλαδή τι να αποίως καντιναβόσο γερμανό σχεοτιπάπου για να κάνει την
προιτημασία του για των ανοικτό στύβο φεύκε πάει αφρική θα μπορούσαμε να κ μεταλευτούμε αυτόν
το πράγμα να γίνουν ύποδομές ενκαταστάσεις προπονεντικό καιντρο ένα ολο κληρωμένο προπονητικώ κέντρο και όλι
αυτί αθλητές αχρειας να πας είναι νια δέκα ώρες στην όιν αφρική ια να κάουν
πρωτημασία τοντά στην αφρική είμαστε το κλείμαα μας μέσιότουν το ίδιο να έχουμε καιέξοδα να
μπορεί να είναι και βιώσιμι ι όλη κατάσταση το αθετικού κέντρου αλλά παράληλα να προσφέριξε
στους οτικούς του αθελτές καλύτερης πιοίτας προπονησης θεωρίς ότι έκλεισες στην καριάα όπως ήθελες όχι
με την ένοια ότι εγώ έπεσα στην περίπτωση του κόβιτ βέβαια ίμουν και σε μια
περίοδομετά το δέκα έξι που στην ουσία τα οτελευταίως μου μεγάλος αγώνας